that guy's creepy the Dos Equis yeah why
is it well cuz you walk into the room
it's all darker then there's a
silhouette of a man with his probably
like lethal guitar then I mean yeah she
was scared when they sent him to me says
like oh [ __ ] am I supposed to do with
this except get scared by it every time
I walk into a room that's why I put him
in the podcast room because I was like
he can't stand in the house I think it's
Julian
remember one time that I pranked you
with it yeah I do that was funny
it was scary marble thinks it's a man he
still does welcome guys to the Jenna and
Julian podcast sorry we were just
talking [ __ ] about our friend I'm
standing right there I mean it's [ __ ]
cool and funny
it's a hysterical thing to have it is
just are you dark there's events when
you know if you want to have a party but
your friends aren't available you can
just leave it part of the dust like
easement yeah so doesn't feel as
normally where which is nice true
it's nice um welcome to the Jenna
Jillian hi guys oh my god that working
guys um I wanted to talk about the fact
that for the first time in my entire
life although I know this has existed
for a while we got our entire life our
entire life we got groceries delivered
to the house it was amazing
today it happened - we decided to do it
today and we got the groceries today I
can't like I just can't even because I
thought you know I've heard of some of
the ones that exists but last time I
checked none of them delivered in our
area so we checked out Amazon fresh or
whatever yeah and it was like oh you pay
$300 for the year and I was like that's
a [ __ ] commitment I don't know I
don't know if I'm ready for all that
Amazon yeah we shopped around though we
looked at a bunch of the front one yeah
today I was like no it's got to be
possible to get some food today okay
yeah I want it now I want my groceries
now but I don't want to waste my [ __ ]
day dilly-dallying around [ __ ] the
grocery store until you pay a little bit
extra how much like a delivery fee we
paid like 10% of our groceries which is
not much know if they're bringing it to
your house there's checking out at the
grocery aisle they're doing all the hard
it's a good tip and her name is Nikki
and she was lovely she was lovely we
instacart instacart is what we used it
was very good it is yet to give us any
trouble we use it one time but yeah
we'll probably do it again dude it was
like life-changing I don't know why I've
ever gone to the grocery store when that
exists well I mean you pointed out that
going to the grocery store just really
sucks up your day it's like it's not a
quick thing if you need to get food for
the whole weekend oh yeah because you
you sit around you you plan out your
meals for the week and what you need to
get and like then you go there you get
all your groceries you pack them all up
in your [ __ ] car you drive my home
you unload them all in your house I mean
it's not a short task for anyone unless
you're going to the store every single
day just getting a couple of things yeah
which I feel like it's different on the
east and west coast because when I lived
on the East Coast most people do their
shopping for the entire week or for two
weeks so everybody has like big giant
carts full of food whereas here you go
to the grocery store the aisles aren't
even really set up for you to have a lot
of groceries they pull out that little
thing for you to put a couple things on
there like it's totally different and I
feel like because on the East Coast you
have winter and [ __ ] like that most
people don't go to the store everyday
whereas here there's tons of people that
go to the store every day and all they
have and their [ __ ] cart is like a
loaf of bread and like some [ __ ]
breathe has a kale yeah it's it's a
little bit frustrating because more
often than not when I go grocery
shopping someone will make a comment
like oh that's a lot of food and I feel
like being like can you shut the [ __ ] up
like I don't want to come to the store
every day yeah also shut up period
anyway like I hate everyone the
groceries anyway comments on anything
you have doing like oh why would you say
anything about something I put my cart
right why would you ask me how many bags
I want if I'm buying bags you make that
car bro
if I have a cart full of groceries when
I say yes to bags and they're like okay
how many and I'm like you know what
you're paid to eyeball this in two bags
not me I'm not gonna make that decision
there's too much stress just too much
pressure I'm not sure it's in other
steel California is the only California
you you have to pay for either ten cents
per bag or you can bring your green
valuable bags which is a great thing in
theory but then
every time how many I want every time no
as many as you need to get 10 cents I'm
a big baller you can just go crazy on
the bags yeah every time you check out
every single time without fail they're
like how many bags
how many every time I get stressed I
don't know let's say one and then I'll
carry the rest of it with my hands right
it's it's a little ridiculous or my
favorite one is when you have like a
bunch of [ __ ] and they're like how many
bags you want and I'm like I don't know
and they're like okay just one and I'm
like woah how how would I need just one
that yeah like look at what I bought
there's a grocery cart items no the best
also is when they start just putting
things in your cart for you not in bags
and they don't ask you like you'll put
milk and juice and all this stuff in
your cart and I'm like okay well I guess
I'm just gonna have to carry that with
my hands and bat my hands and now my
hands it's it's a little inferior they
need to like be a little more Oprah on
the bags like you get it back and you
get a bag you get five bags you get as
many as your grocery cart needs but
that's just one of the things that uh
another thing is is when I'm looking for
an item and they can't like that they're
they don't know the answer like to we're
on the right and they're just I can
sorry
well I leave and I'm like yeah one time
we were looking for something one time
we were looking for shallots and or like
tahini like you wanted to make second
hummus yeah and nobody has a clue what
you're talking about like shallots
they're kind of like an onion they like
I don't know we don't know and then you
search around the grocery store for
hours and you find them that they
prepackaged them in bags are you I'll
cut up yeah like well you know it just
isn't helpful
it always is crazy to me that like I
understand that it's gonna happen where
a grocery store grocery store worker is
gonna not know what you're talking about
what always like kind of confuses me is
when they're like they don't know what
you're talking about and then they're
just like or they lie to you yeah yeah
yeah yeah I to you and they're like yeah
it's over in Aisle 4 it's like the
furthest out from them so they don't
have to come
no man there's nothing here yeah it's a
little frustrating yeah
but anyways I'm not sure I'm ever gonna
go back to I'm sure we'll have to go to
the store sometimes some point yeah I
don't think that it can replace you
actually grocery shopping every once in
a while but it's really nice when
there's things that you know you're
gonna need and want to tell them do it
because then you don't waste your
[ __ ] day that's for you or at least a
few hours yeah any time you can save
time it's worth that [ __ ] we paid
[ __ ] ten fifteen dollars for somebody
to do it for us yeah which is really
lovely
yeah worth it more than worth it
although we looked into some of these
other ones there's one like farm house
or farm store I can't member a lot of
them just felt really ancient their apps
sucked and well yeah those said but the
other ones were too like specific like I
forget which what it was called it was
like farm whatever farm basket I don't
[ __ ] know and you go on their website
and it's just uh Kristen Bell's face and
she's like oh that's my carrot that's
how you know it's gonna be good right so
all you can do really is like pick out
these like farm baskets essentially and
it would never be enough groceries for
anyone it's like also what happens if
you want like I don't know salsa or
something that doesn't come in the
basket no you gotta buy that I mean it's
good in theory if you want one basket of
food ya know it's more like it's more of
like a novelty I think yeah like a
licked away the pre meal like blue apron
or they send you all the materials to
make a meal for sure but that's not a
[ __ ] I looked at it and I was like oh
they have a good gluten-free thing
that'd be a game to me it was it was a
box of like celery tomatoes a dozen eggs
and like this tiny little slice of like
chicken and I'm like Julian would die if
that was his groceries you would be
ravenous within an hour yeah but I mean
it's still really cool and I'm really
excited that we did that me too that was
really awesome and I feel ancient
PewDiePie tweeted me that he's been
doing it for a year I feel so left
behind I know well it's something that's
been happening for a while we just have
never done it and now that we are it's
like oh it's kind of like when post
mates having like where the [ __ ] have we
been well my dad and also my brother
my brother lives in like Oregon and my
dad lives in upstate New York and I know
that my dad has been getting certain
groceries deliver frozen for years like
since we were kids he'll get like a
[ __ ] half a cow and like [ __ ] like
that
you think Devon does that too yeah um my
brother but there's plenty of people in
the United States that get portions of
their groceries delivered which I always
thought was like kind of stupid and he's
coming to ative Wow yeah I'm like well
then why would I just go to the store
yeah but it makes sense for a lot of
people especially if the store is but
yeah half an hour ya know for each
situation it definitely is you know
varies in terms of life what makes sense
and what doesn't but I just feel [ __ ]
stupid man I feel happy and I feel glad
I didn't have to go into a grocery store
that always end up getting frustrated
with stuff there everything's
frustrating yeah and then you always get
and you're too hungry and too thirsty to
be there anyways so then you get skipped
too much stuff yeah - yeah if you go
there when you're too hungry you get too
much stuff you go there when you're full
you're like I don't need anything yeah
it's like okay well if you're online
it's like I'll just have them deliver
yeah it was pretty cool it's great um
this is not a sponsored by the way so
well not sponsored at all um we did want
to talk about something that we really
like never talked about we always we
always are you're good moving on yeah we
always move like discuss things that
make us laugh and things that we love
about our dogs but we don't really ever
talk about things that we don't like
that they do
Julien hates certain things about the
dog I think every human being on earth
hate certain things that their animal
does and we figured he just talked about
the things that are large and we don't
like kick it off just kick it off how
about you can't take a single inch of a
step anywhere without Kermit being under
your heel it's all of you and it's too
much she's very nervous it's too much
he is absolutely high-strung to the
point where he thinks if you are more
than a foot away from him at any given
time you mean not not anyone I'm Jenna
so Lee um and I've known Jenna for over
three years right yeah so you'd think he
would have gotten accustomed to me which
marble does like when Jen is not around
you know model we're cool but Kermit
like he thinks the world is going to
collapse on his little Italian Greyhound
body if he's not right next to her at
all times and it's it's I get it like
it's he depends on you and he's needy
and that's but it's it's gotten to a
point it is at it's been at a point when
um well why'd you tell him we did this
morning what Kermit did this yeah okay
so Jenna doesn't wake up from there
crying or barking or anything she's got
90 she's got an immune to it from years
of being from years of them crying wolf
yeah that's all they do though you know
they don't ever cry anything but wolf
they don't know what crying other than
wolf is yeah I probably know what anyway
so she doesn't wake up when they cry or
bark I do but I was up anyway I was up
like two hours something before Jenna
this morning and I was downstairs doing
stuff and the bedroom door upstairs was
open
so I could hear Kermit crying which if
you can kind of imagine I'm in the
office listening this stuff on my
computer and I still hear is crying on
top of Tomas Dezi leaning body and like
this is like oh my god crying like he's
trying to wake you up with a crime and I
kee chose he chose crying as a method to
wake you Julian after years of that
wouldn't you
become accustomed to talking yeah
[ __ ] wish I could help
well normally the thing is normally up I
don't know what it is I always wake up
when he cries but I was up and he starts
crying and it's so loud that I can hear
from downstairs somewhere you know what
I'm not gonna deal with this I walk
upstairs and I pick him up Kermit no
more crying you can't cry mommy awake so
I pick him up take him downstairs peach
falls me because she's good about
following me and going where I go and I
bring him downstairs but I shut the
bedroom door so he can't run back up
there so we're hanging out downstairs
we're walking in the kitchen I put him
down like to go outside because peach is
heading outside and he does this thing
we puts on the brakes and he turns
directions it goes the other way like
boo boo and he like makes this noise
like he's getting shot at how to police
and he Sprint's upstairs like you saw
that vlog of mine when he Sprint's up
the stairs that's what he did he like
superhuman speed because he's scared
of me I don't know and so he sprints up
the stairs he like basically like jumps
and like tries to like shoulder charge
the [ __ ] door open because he knows
I'm like behind him and he's a fan of
him the doors not out thing so I don't
even go upstairs I just let him do his
[ __ ] weird little garbage stick and
he goes like clawing at the door you
know and then he stops and then I'm like
okay whatever he'll figure it out you
know he'll deal with the situation as he
needs to so I lay on the couch I'm
hanging out with peach doing a couple
things on my phone and 10-15 minutes
passes and I'm like where's Kermit like
he's not in the bedroom the door shut
where did he go and I'm like Kermit and
I look up on like the mezzanine like a
little balcony in our living room thing
and he just trots over and he just like
looks at me he just like looks in a
chart cuz he just like looks at me and
he's like and like hermit did you just
wait up there are you just waiting sorry
I'm like rambling but um yeah he's
incredibly nervous and it puts him and
everyone involved in situations where
it's like why are we why are we dealing
with his high-strung nerves
why can't we just like everything's
gonna be [ __ ] okay everything is
always know how we also always talk
about the fact that Kermit doesn't
really even like me he just needs me
because hermit for those of you that
have watched you know in my vlogs or
videos where where I'm interacting with
Kermit regularly since I got him since
day one like he needs me to hold him and
like feed him and pay attention to him
but then he's a very rude dog like he
will bite me when he's had it he's a
rude dog we don't drive unless he walks
all over me and I know it yeah which you
know go ahead and let all of your bad
dog pairs yeah we're gonna get all of it
out in the comments go let them all out
and you can ask me if I give a [ __ ] cuz
I don't know he's my dog um but I do I
like to baby him I choose the baby him
and when we go out of the house Kermit
is the most well behaved dog he listens
to me he's the only dog that I can fully
through and through trust that country
Kermit will always listen to me and
understand like what our life saying
that life
in commands when he needs to pay
attention I've seen you in the flushing
it was a wonderful dog when we're not in
the house yeah when we're in the house
he is the worst dog in the house he is
[ __ ] just doesn't give a [ __ ] about
you and what you want he only wants what
Kermit wants he's a breath he's very
rude yeah he's a brat and then on top of
it he's very dramatic so it's like when
he's not being like mean and bullying
generally he's like he's stressing
everyone out yeah by being so stressed
out yeah for no reason but I mean the
majority of the time he sort of just
sits around and does Kermit things
you're very relaxed you guys know what
the majority of the time is because
we've log it and we talk about all that
you can't yeah you can't be like hey I'm
gonna pick up Kermit now he will run
away from you like it's so embarrassing
when people come over and they see
Kermit and I go and pick him up and he
[ __ ] bolts away from me like he
doesn't want to be touched yeah if I
hold him he'll bite me he'll wait till I
put him down like there's only so much
like chastising I can do to Kermit
because he'll stop after a little while
but it will never stop him from wanting
to do it like he just what he is a rude
dog in the house yeah but then outside
of the house he's wonderful and sweet
and he chills like he's just a really
good boy when we're not in his domain
Jeremy hmm but I mean yeah he's he's a
weird guy he's a very needy guy and he's
a weird dog but he's he follows me
everywhere everywhere everywhere you
can't make a move without him trying to
follow you I know like I'll go to the
bathroom he comes with me in the
bathroom every single time and Julian
always makes fun of me for it but if I
try and like pet him while we're in
there he'll run away from me it's if he
moves you but he doesn't want you
follows me and he runs away from me but
when I'm up late like editing videos
you'll refuse to go to the bed with
Julian refuse to go upstairs he needs to
sit with me he needs to sit in my shirt
yeah but like it I don't even think that
he wants to be near me he just he needs
to be comforted as very
hissing guy I'll say something I don't
like about peach I think that peach has
destroyed more belongings than both of
my dogs combined it over their entire
lifetime you know
yeah peaches are [ __ ] uh she I think
she has more energy than both of them
ever had she's very destructive with her
energy though for a while she's starting
to tone down now yeah for a while it was
like anything she could physically carry
with her mouth was wrecked right like
things that you didn't think dogs could
get ahold of she would wreck I think
that the worst was every single time we
left the house she still does it she
would chew the couch pillow she's
getting better though yes she is but I
told you my trick of how I leave those
like square brown pillows with the open
so they can tear the stuffing out of
them that was like my dog hack because
karma used to do it like they can tear
the stuffing out then when you get home
you put it back in there it's like a
never ending toy so it's a never ending
toy
if the phils there need to chew pillows
but they don't destroy any of your new
pillows well peach wasn't having any of
that she did a little bit and then she
moved on to the couch pillows and so
they're the ones that like you sit with
your back against they said they've been
slowly getting less and less full of
life yes oh god she really does like
take a toll on him for that child um
she's over a year old now though so
hopefully she will stop chewing but she
loves the work no I'm a gazelle was the
worst that's the second worse underwear
is the word she destroys my underwear
which is really frustrating but because
she for a while we were trying to figure
out how she was getting my underwear and
then Jenna caught her opening car door
opening plummets from its commodity
close position she was opening it I was
like little T Julius I pulled stop
leaving your clothes places I'm like
Julian I'm telling you I'm not leaving
them anywhere oh no ugh she's getting on
I didn't believe you and then I saw like
houdini'd my [ __ ] drawer open but now
we got a dresser in your closet is that
problem solved um no but the the other
worst one was I had left a box of
tampons
like on the somewhere where she could
jump and get it because that weak member
we caught her doing that to my best in
the front hall I had this furry vest and
he's hung up hi
and I was like there's fur on the ground
where's this coming from
she we caught her she was jumping
leaving as high as you could daddy a
little bit each time and peach can jump
up into our arms it's like in our chest
she has hops she was jumping up there
and that's how she ate corn my llama
from Australia yep
I'll pack him in alpaca my stuff gel
packet from Australia but um I had left
a box of tampons somewhere where she
could leap and get it thinking it's out
of her reach and uh we go upstairs to
the bedroom and there are like so many
tampons in different states of like open
and unopened and the the plastic
applicators and just like tampons like
fully ripped apart everywhere and it was
the most ridiculous thing I have ever
seen
yeah like she really really really just
she well she also is one of the like one
of the things about her is that she
cannot help herself know so she might
use tampons by the way it's a new matter
of intense um she knows a lot of time
what she's doing is really really
naughty like she's she knows she'll
actively do something well I know for a
fact she knows when I'm taking food
after we've eaten or it's chewing a
pillow or whatever it is she a hundred
that knows it's bad but she can't resist
like I feel like just now she although
in peaches defense this has not happened
you know this isn't me I was upstairs
he's not let's try to turn on the lights
and there's a puddle of pee at the end
of the bed like she had just done it
within 30 seconds of me turning my back
she that's not normal
but she I don't know she's very very
[ __ ] at yeah and our dogs don't pee
on our beds so don't [ __ ] I think
that they just see everywhere rot
animals but no um she like you know
catch her chewing like a headset or some
cords or some [ __ ] thing that she
knows she or he taking food like I've
vlogged heard multiple times taking food
because I set up the camera because I
know if the food's there and we are not
she cannot resist like hermit will
resist pee marble will resist because
they know that is they know
get it yeah um but PG can't and it's
like no the funniest thing about peach
and and knowing what she can and can't
have is that when she has something
she's playing with something that she
can't have she'll bring it to you and
play with it like the day she had my
[ __ ] caterpillars and when they were
still babies like I had them back ajar
they were on top of the kitchen table
she left up there got the caterpillars I
was sitting outside on the lawn chair
she came out and dropped them like on me
while she was playing with them like
peach those are my [ __ ] caterpillars
are you kidding me but she'll that's
what she does she'll try and come play
with whatever she's not supposed to be
playing with on top of you like food is
the best though to like if you eat
something and it's on the kitchen table
or somewhere where she can get up to it
she'll bring the bag like out to you
like drop it on top of you like where's
what is her thought process what thought
process I think she's a she's a baby
she's naughty she's naughty but she's
gonna be good though eventually yes she
has to turn good well she's the smartest
out of your head and in terms of marbles
nobody it's it's it happens a little bit
at a time we'll get tomorrow's on one
side yeah but like like for the first of
it was the energy that started dying now
well first it was the peeing she stopped
being in the house you know that was the
first thing that I needed to accomplish
because you know for like the first
couple months I develop this like
fatherly instinct that if I felt any
movement in the bed and pop out pick her
up and take her outside she would pee on
the bed while we were singing as a puppy
does but it was first that then it was
the energy and now it's starting to be
the chewing thing she started slowly but
surely she's getting a hold of like you
really just can't [ __ ] chazer that's
it I mean everything else is totally
fine really good dog he's a good dog
she's a very good I'm very lucky for
more than one reason for forgetting
peach you know she's beautiful and she's
sweet she's got the greatest energy but
she's also a very smart dog
so she listens in the house unlike
permit yeah and you know as she's
getting better outside of the house -
I've walked her and taking her places
well I know well peach is the perfect
mix of Carmen and marbles Kermit is you
know will not listen to you ever in the
house ever unless you say do you want a
treat yeah you'll never come unless
you're like we're going to bed
and marbles will listen to elinoz marble
will always listen to in the house
marble is sweetheart in the house he
will coddle you he will love you you
leave the house that [ __ ] is a
demon trap there's no controlling marvel
outside permit is wonderful outside the
house and peach is relatively good at
each is good as bad both inside all
right
yes but marbles will not I can't get him
to listen no he's very animalistic
outside the house yes it's primal I hate
when people are like you can train any
dog to do anything I'm like you have not
met marbles or others similarly fiery
Chihuahua or small dogs he when he gets
going outside the house he's literally
like he has no family
he doesn't know Jenna is yeah he doesn't
know anything but whatever he's fixing
it on like he's okay in dog parks but
like if he sees another dog or something
that he's having a hard time with um
I've had to pick him up on his leash
like swing him I wasn't his fault or
father his mother calling calling
Pauline pulling on him and he will not
listen to you and there was a dog coming
at him yeah that was someone else's
fault who let their husky walk free oh
that one [ __ ] [ __ ] man this is one
of my pet peeves when it say it says
like don't walk your dog off leash and
people are just like oh sure whatever
but then I'm okay with the people that
have their dogs super well-trained where
they don't their dog doesn't even look
ok do you and you probably have some
certification that says you're allowed
to have your dog wherever you want
these people have no regard and then
your dogs are on leashes their dogs are
not their dogs approach your dogs that's
not OK no that's not okay at all they
need to stay with their owners this dog
came around a corner on a hike it was a
husky no it wasn't it was like a Chow
Chow it was something [ __ ] crazy it
looked like a wolf
she was [ __ ] public it actually
looked like a wolf cuz we were well we
were up in the mountain at we're up in
the mountains and I was like ok we were
about to hit this corner about like 25
yards away and I see this giant dog turn
the corner I'm like wait hold on Jenna
like what's what's going on what's his
way she's like no it's fine I'm sure
like whoever's walking it has control
ok he's locked yes stop so really were
daring at us yes but I you know shits
gonna get real good well we keep walking
and then the dog just approaches that so
current and marbles or Kermit and Peach
are like freaking out and retreating
into the
yeah Bush so I picked them up and
marbles is like freaking out but also
like freaking out attacked like scared
fighting and pee Jenna because the doc
kept walking towards Marvel's was right
with the [ __ ] so Jenna picked the leash
up and grabbed marbles and we were like
the lady came over was like oh hey like
cool dogs we're just like what the [ __ ]
are you doing like got [ __ ] on all
kinds of [ __ ] xanax and [ __ ] I like
it
first of all the dog walked around the
corner did that stop and like you know
you get that [ __ ] it's got seized
like red think it sees blood and [ __ ]
wants to get marbled so then he throws
down its tracks and then all of a sudden
does that like low crouched sort of like
run walk towards Mario was aggressive
stalking is aggressive so that's why
Marvel's freaked the [ __ ] out but that
woman saw nothing wrong with her dog
being off leash where it's good she's a
silly marked everywhere
please have your dog on leash and also
you know that place we relate to go
hiking and we've seen on multiple
occasions rattlesnakes all over the
place and these people that are on their
little stupid [ __ ] high horses oh
he's a good dog it doesn't really matter
it's not only for your safety other dogs
safety your dog's safety like your dog
could get killed by a [ __ ] snake
because you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah you
know what I mean look [ __ ] you oh and
then they'll they're those people
they're like yeah my dog totally ate
someone else's dog but it was their
dog's fault for being a small chihuahua
like dude lady you can Julian slow
blinking hard right now oh yeah my dog
totally died he got bit by a rattlesnake
but like he was a good dog oh well you
were great dog owners because that's
what happens to good dogs a good dog
owners they die mmm well don't say that
I mean tragedies [ __ ] happen no I'm
just saying like that kind of thing like
well it's a preventable thing do - I
mean it's preventable when people just
are being responsible dog owners but
anyways we didn't mean to get into this
rant
yeah that is a ring you're more [ __ ]
on our own dogs and avila stuff although
and there there are several awfully
off-leash dog places where we've gone
with the dogs and like they're good in
Big Bear during the day you can't do
that
need to say close because of coyotes and
bears and [ __ ] although they're good
outside they listen marvels not always
to be trusted he's a shifty little
[ __ ] he'll go wherever he wants iam
because he's hiding in tall grass but we
were in Runyon Canyon or whatever when
my friends were in town remember and we
were walking just Carmen marbles this
was pre peach and Kermit really just
wanted to walk like in other people's
past this is so fun so he would walk
like you know couple paces in front of
us to whoever was in front of us and he
would walk so close in between other
people's legs that they would turn
around because they could feel Kermit's
like wet nose on their cat like he would
just completely trace my I just want to
cheese
walk in there pal sofa he's so weird
though it's so good yeah yeah he's such
a weird dog I would say the only thing
marbles really does is just his
unnecessary aggression in the house in
the bargain not barking but also
unnecessary aggression in the house well
towards people when they come in me in
the morning when he forgets who you are
tell them what he does in the morning in
the morning I'll wake up I tend to wake
up before Jenna whether it's five
minutes or a couple hours anyway every
time I wake up I see him like take
position on top of her body like I'm
going to attack it so he like suddenly
sees me what sometimes he'll cuddle me
in the morning be like hey good morning
but other times I'll wake up go to bath
and come back and he's he's posted up
his butt - Jenna
looking at me like that Jared don't like
all right dude but no she ain't touch me
and a Killa denied 'totally hams it up
with me he long he wants nothing more
than hanging out with me tonight so he's
a he's a little confused but it's very
cute and I would just say the the
barking in that and then the
morning-time aggression I could do
without yeah I mean he likes to go
outside and he likes to use his little
voice yes and him and carmit our little
brothers and they love to chase
squirrels and barn barker rosea and they
like you know if kids are riding by in
the neighborhood they'll bark yeah but I
honestly I will put up with all of that
all the time because for some of it for
me especially when I have them at
different points in my life
near alone
you you're in a house alone like when
you're not here like it's invaluable to
me to have like other living beings that
will always let you know at like the
tiniest little noise that's something
what the [ __ ] is happening no I mean it
that means that I have to endure years
of senseless barking yes but it can be a
bit of the middle ground right because
it's not like they're up at night
barking whatever they like to bark
outside and they bark and people are at
the door or when things are happening
whatever sometimes marbles has like a
noisy day but like for the most part at
night if you hear them bark like you
need to [ __ ] and pay attention yep
yep although they don't they um tres I'm
trying to make words good words uh um
the first few times that they felt an
earthquake here they didn't even wake up
they didn't feel it at all the time when
we lived in the old place they won't
even started barking they bartered
earthquake for like 30 seconds but like
but that was an intense we were I was
like the episode yeah um but they don't
really Park it like earthquakes I've
noticed cuz we felt a few yeah they
haven't seen come on I think it has to
be kind of significant for them to
really borrow it remember there's one
like we're outside here you feel like
one hard shake yeah I mean and they're
all just like laying on the couch like
they think that someone is just like
bumped yeah yeah I think if that makes
me nervous
I'm like I don't know if I can trust
your warning system guys we can they'll
know the delivery guys here is when he
[ __ ] parks his car oh yeah they're
good they are good but what else don't
you like about them anything I don't
know I think we ranted on them enough
honestly you Julian had just had it
today with a hermit and peach peeing on
the bed really who does that
what are you an invisible Julian's also
had it with me sometimes because I
really I really do like to baby them
well you I think some of your babying
with Kermit at least and also Marcus but
listen it's Kermit it amplifies the
problem like he's very high-strung and
scared and nervous and weird around me
and anyone but Jenna and the way that
sometimes you pick her and pick him her
pick him up and like it's okay he's like
okay well maybe if I do
act freaked the [ __ ] out all the time
I'll get detention and I'm like well
maybe that does not I mean won't let me
it they're not even 30 seconds after
peach peed on the bed not a couple
minutes cuz you had gone downstairs
Kermit you had closed the patio door
upstairs and blocked Kermit out why did
he wander out there I thought he was in
the bathroom with you
Carly gets locked out of places a lot or
locked into place oh my god he's the
middle child - dude he's [ __ ] weird
and he creeps and then he can't see him
he's like a little stealth little
[ __ ] anyways so you had left him out
on the patio by accident and closed the
door and I was in the bathroom like
brushing my hair or whatever and I just
hear like like he was very patient
sometimes sometimes he freaks out one
time he got locked in the garage and he
was like scream crying in there and when
he gets locked into your closet and just
really just diarrhea everywhere he was
so nervous but this time when he's on
the patio he's very sweet and patient
like he was just clung and then when I
let him in he was okay just whatever
yeah
like sometimes he freaks out sometimes
it doesn't he's not always know is I
think for them honestly for the most
part our dogs are great and they're not
bad and they're good and they have good
energies and they're manageable but
sometimes they're not that at all you
know what makes me upset about marbles
sometimes like every time that he drinks
he needs to throw a little bit of it up
he can ever drink one over that choking
well it's not throw up to your videos he
was killed drink and even even if you
like make him slow down you make them
whatever was he needs to go and like
just get alone and Iggy's forget how to
breathe through their mouths sometimes
I'll be like hmm just randomly nothing's
wrong and just forgot that they can
breathe through their nose yes and they
also I know I feel and they also when we
leave the house they try and make it so
you can't leave my Kermit will grab my
leg like he'll do the bling it's like
wait I clinched on our lid man
but yeah I'm glad that you got to get
some of it off yeah thank you guys for
letting us vent about our animals and
some little bit about other people's
animals but mostly ours [ __ ] that link
if you guys have certain things that
your dogs do let us know in the comments
please cuz I love reading that kind of
stuff yeah and also it makes you feel
about you're weird and it also makes me
feel like a better person for kind of
hating the [ __ ] that peach does
sometimes because I know other people
feel the same way and and anyone that
wants to leave a holier-than-thou
comment about how to treat your dogs
like dogs I mean you probably just write
it you desire it and then mail it to
yourself
Oh Peter Peters hiring I think you wanna
spend a day I feel like there's a middle
ground between treating your dog the way
that you're supposed to quote treat your
dog and you know loving them like
they're one of your family members also
there's another thing called being
really [ __ ] judgmental so maybe we do
something different than other people
would that doesn't mean you need to
impart your judgment I know I love the
people that are like oh my god you're
[ __ ] carpets such a mess like it only
takes five minutes to vacuum your carpet
like yeah but it takes a lot more than
five minutes to vacuum your entire
[ __ ] house every day when you have a
puppy that will chew anything also also
if we want to keep our car the carpet on
vacuums for a couple days will do that
it'll be fine and we're gonna not give a
[ __ ] with you but thank you guys so much
for hanging out with us this week if you
Mazal the end high-five
cuz that was a lot of ranting yeah so
this is a very odd cast we'll be back
with another probably less ran to your
podcast possibly with a guest possibly
without again next time on the Jen and
Jillian podcast make sure if you guys
don't want to sit on YouTube and watch
us we are on southbound on iTunes as
well wait for free oh we love you guys
give me some waffle fives and if dr.
pepper oh you had chicken and waffles
oh so good right any nice okay okay I
love you guys I'll see you next week I
thought